tarek it's a pleasure to talk to you
about your book the dual Pakistan is one
of those countries that everybody in the
United States is talking about but
unlike the weather everyone thinks they
seem to know that something that they
can do about it in fact really people
don't understand Pakistan I hope that
people do some reading of this latest
series of books that have come out it
above all yours as we talk here they're
still I guess cleaning up the mess at
the disaster site in Islamabad where the
the Marriott was bombed and we now know
that almost the entire Pakistani
leadership including the president and
the Prime Minister were supposed to have
had a dinner there the very evening of
the the bombing that they changed at the
last minute which means that the
Pakistani leadership could have been
decimated leaving aside America's
interests in fighting al-qaeda from the
standpoint of Pakistan's interests do
you think that this is a mortal threat
to the Pakistani state and do you think
that they're equipped to be able to deal
with it going forward
Bob there were there was another reason
for the attack according to the
Pakistani media which I've been reading
quite closely one is of course that the
cabinet and the president were going to
be eating of that hotel and changed
their venue at the last minute the other
reports now surfacing inside Pakistan
are that a whole group of Marines
arrived with steel boxes which
circumvented security weren't put
through the scanners on September the
17th and that news of this spread
rapidly but who knows whether it was one
or the other
the fact is that the escalation inside
Pakistan in my view is a direct result
of the escalation of the war inside the
tribal areas of Pakistan following
decision by the United
it's to go in whenever they wished and
drop bombs sending Predator drones
consider violating their country's
sovereignty all the reports coming in
from that region suggest that this has
seen a big increase in Pashtun these are
the people who live there the Pashtuns
in Pashtun nationalism against the
foreign presence a report on the BBC by
one of their veteran South Asian
correspondent so and Bennett Jones a few
days ago reported that he had been
talking to liberal secular beer a
beardless festoons in the capital
Peshawar and he said they were just
desperate saying you are pushing us away
by the way you are behaving in this part
of the world and soon we will have no
alternative but to fight against you now
when people like this start saying this
to the BBC in public it's a sign of how
bad things are
so I think the mariette is one episode
in an escalation that is taking place in
that region as a result of the war in
Afghanistan going badly wrong obviously
these militants the jihadis called them
what you will are now threatening the
Pakistani leadership because they see
this leadership as complicit in what the
United States is doing I don't think
that they are anywhere near strong
enough to take on the Pakistani military
which is a very large force but I think
they could certainly capable of creating
mayhem as they did at the Marriot you
say in your book that the threat of a
jihadi takeover of Pakistan is remote
and of course the religious parties the
fundamentalist parties don't do well in
elections and so forth you also say
though in that if the United States
attacks Pakistan crosses the border if
the United States were to occupy parts
of the Northwest Frontier areas that
this could cause the Pakistani army to
split that there's a great deal of
sympathy among the army
for the militants and that in fact in
that event you say in your book the
possibility of a jihadi takeover would
increase could actually become
conceivable now we've seen in the last
weeks exactly that we've seen the United
States begin as they did in Southeast
Asia when they blamed Cambodia for being
the the read out for the Vietcong
they've now expanded the Afghan war
directly into Pakistan so does that mean
that the Army in Pakistan could split
that the appeal of the jihadis and the
militants and the Taliban could increase
to the point where it actually becomes a
threat to the Pakistan State well this
is the million-dollar question as they
say Bob I mean I'm very nervous to be
blunt with you I think that the unity of
the Pakistani High Command of which they
are very proud has never been broken so
far but if there were to be a direct US
military presence I'm not now talking
about cross-border bombing raids these
create real anger and bitterness in the
region I'm talking if the u.s. decided
to go beyond that in Phase three of this
latest offensive and actually send
troops in that I think would really put
very severe strains on the Pakistani
military leadership as it is and this is
not a fact much talked about in the West
Pakistan and it's Army has lost more
soldiers in the battle against the
jihadists on the northwest frontier than
any single NATO country Pakistani
soldiers have died some have given
themselves up rather than fight young
Pakistani officers sent for a tour of
duty to the Northwest Frontier
some of them prefer to take early
retirement and move out of the Army
together why because they do not like
the orders given to them to shoot their
own people regardless of who they are
it's this that creates the
tenshun if the US were to make a serious
move into Pakistan I think the army
would find it very difficult to preserve
its unity unless of course it decided to
resist and fight back which is what the
Pakistani generals are saying that if
there's a direct invasion they would
resist whether they would or quotas of
course another question but the reason
they are saying that is to preserve the
unity of this armed force inside the
country which after all is the only
institution with which the u.s. is
preserved and maintained friendly
relations now over 60 years so if
they're going to lose this institution
in Pakistan the consequences are
unpredictable mm-hmm
you know in Iraq the site of the other
war besides the Afghan Pakistan war it's
often said that there's no apparent
Nelson Mandela there there's no apparent
unifying figure no politician who
commands national loyalty and respect
the way Mandela did in South Africa but
it's clear that that's also true in
Pakistan you you call in your book
Pakistani politics you compared to a
desert and you say there's not even an
imaginable Oasis there you're very hard
on the Pakistani leadership over decades
is there any possibility in that country
of a strong authentic nationalist leader
or leadership developing is it is there
anything on the horizon or if not what's
the potential for that where would that
come from well official politics in
Pakistan the two principal parties the
party of the late benazir bhutto which
she bequeathed in her will to her son
and her husband till the Sun came of age
the fact that this could happen in
Pakistan is of course deeply depressing
that all the dignitaries in function
of this party allowed this to happen
without raising their voices in protest
is a sign of what politics in that
country is the opposition to the PPP
comes from the Sharif brothers and their
political organization the Muslim lead
both these parties and the gang of
politicians Musharraf relied on in his
last five years a deeply mired in
corruption Bob and everyone now said
they loot the country they make money
from being in power power for them is a
springboard to loot and accumulate
wealth and they have all done it so they
are pretty discredited with ordinary
people and we are now talking of a time
when the price of wheat from which
people poor and middle class make their
bread is so high that it's unobtainable
and unavailable and inaccessible to a
large swathe of the population we have a
situation in Pakistan we according to
the latest UN Development statistics
60% of children born in that country are
being born stunted because of
malnutrition these are the scale of the
problems which confront Pakistan's
political leadership and they so far
I've been incapable military or
political leadership of dealing with
these problems now Nelson Mandela is a
far cry in in Pakistan but there is one
figure who emerged over the last few
years who really won the respect of
ordinary people in a way that I haven't
seen in Pakistan for a very long time
and that was the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court this was a guy who gave
judgments that favoured the poor who
judged without fear or favor
he made himself extremely unpopular with
the Pakistani establishment and the
Western establishment because he refused
to accept that people could be
disappeared off the streets
and he was removed and sacked in a very
brutal cold-blooded fashion he remains
one of the most popular figures in the
country and I have written that were
there to be a direct election for the
presidency which there isn't the
president is elected indirectly there is
no doubt that justice Chaudhary would
sweep the board but he is an individual
he is not a man with a political
organization behind him but he is deeply
respected and that lawyers struggle a
constitutional struggle for the
separation of powers between the
judiciary and the government that is
what that movement was about was very
popular in Pakistan in every city poor
people rallied to the cause of the
Supreme Court because it was the only
body at that time which they felt was
defending them so it was very
short-sighted of the West to demand of
the judge not be taken back this was the
demand the US ambassador accepted by
Musharraf answered very and I think it's
a tragedy so it's not that there aren't
people but they are not people who are
allowed to function in that society you
know in your book you you provide a rich
history of Pakistan that that I think
provides context for people you you go
back to the long sad history of various
Pakistani military autocrats who took
over and came and went from and and
their experiments with democracy that
seemed to have been fatally flawed what
is it though that accounts for the fact
that next door in India you have a
thriving democracy they've had their
problems of course with assassinations
and with terrorism over the years but
still they have what seems to be a semi
well-functioning democracy there yet in
Pakistan which after all was united with
India until 1947 Pakistan has been
unable to really establish the the
grounding for democracy certainly is not
because Pakistan is a Muslim country
although detractors of Muslims
probably say that but what's your
explanation what is it in the history of
the two countries that makes it so hard
for democracy to take root there well
the subtitle of my book Bob is Pakistan
on the flight path of American power and
this has been the case since the early
50s onwards that ever since Pakistan as
a country and its ruling elite really
became an asset of the United States
they have done its bidding and the only
institution in that country which the
United States so is functioning and with
which they could deal was the Pakistani
military so every time they felt that
their interests were being threatened by
the possibility of a general election
that might produce a government that
would take Pakistan out of its security
pacts with the u.s. Iran in Turkey which
dominated that region in the 50s and 60s
they asked the army to strike and the
army did and when the army came The
Dictator stayed in power for at least 10
years that's the time span of military
of the rule of each single military
dictator then later on after this
dictator was removed through a mass
insurrection more or less the country
split up because the dictator who
succeeded him while committing in an
election refused to accept the result
so Pakistan and Nixon and Kissinger
tilted towards the dictator so Pakistan
split up in 1972 then you had a brief
period of populist experiments where
great deal was promised by Bain Aziz
fathers of the Carolee Bhutto but very
little was actually delivered on the
ground and Bhutto then became interested
in the idea of developing a nuclear bomb
because India had a nuclear bomb and
Kissinger said to him if you don't
desist we will make a horrible example
out of you
Woodruff's had wrote that in his death
cell it's now been confirmed by others
who were present and they made a
horrible example out of him Amin another
military coup Bhutto arrested on fake
charges in hanged and that period of
general zia-ul-haq was
the most distressing brutal period in
our country's history and that is also
the period when the Russians go into
Afghanistan so Z becomes an absolutely
vital asset for the West to wage the
jihad against the Soviet Union with
encouraging jihadi groups paying for
them to be trained giving them weaponry
and all the monsters that they spawned
at that time are still with us
so the real problem with Pakistan I
think was twofold
one it had an underdeveloped political
class after partition unlike India which
had a very long tradition of politics
against the British Empire most of the
people who came to power in Pakistan had
collaborated with the British during
British imperial rule and now they've
slipped easily into collaborating with
the United States so what I always say
is that there's always been a big US
Lobby in Pakistan a Saudi Lobby in
Pakistan a Chinese Lobby in Pakistan but
there is no Pakistan Lobby within the
elite they govern essentially in the
interests of others is there any chance
that any of the political parties
especially the the PPP the Pakistan
Peoples Party could be transformed or
reformed could emerge as an authentic
standard bearer for Pakistani national
aspirations or do you think we need to
wipe the slate clean and start over
again well it's always difficult to wipe
the slate totally clean once political
parties have been established it's like
sort of you know baseball teams or
soccer clubs they acquire a loyal fan
base who follow them through thick and
thin but I think certainly what needs to
be done is to break with dynasties to
break with this awful feudal tradition
of a political party being run
as a feudal relic you know so I think
that is we need a break with uniforms
but we certainly need a break with
political dynasties there's no ways that
vari would have been remotely close to
power had he not been the widower of the
assassinated benazir bhutto that's the
only reason that he's in power and it's
an embarrassment because he's not a
serious figure he's essentially a
businessman interested in making money
he is no idea and he surrounded himself
with cronies who are now posturing
around the place but with who enjoyed
very little respect
I think Pakistan does need a set of
proper political parties which actually
act on behalf of the people whose votes
they seat none exist there and of course
if you say this to some of the
politicians running Pakistan they're
saying well democracy is going bad
everywhere so why should it be special
here and there is of course an element
of truth in it but that is not it
shouldn't be true you know the fact that
democracy may is going bad anywhere for
Pakistani shouldn't be an excuse not to
do anything or to accept a very corrupt
system you you seem to have in the book
occasional mixed feelings about the
Bhutto's there they are the political
dynasty I guess they've compared
themselves to the Kennedys and and other
American political dynasties but but you
suggest that both South Africa Ali
Bhutto the the president who was
overthrown in 1977 by General Zia and
then hang two years later and his
daughter
behnazir had potential had progressive
instincts talk a little bit first about
the father
you knew him of course way back as early
as the 1960s I guess yeah what potential
did he have what could he have done as
president and where did
he go wrong what what where did he make
his Shakespearean fatal mistakes I think
basically you have to understand Witsel
figoratti put to the founder of this
Porto dynasty political dynasty that he
was essentially his formative years in
politics were under a military dictator
he was a member of Ayub cabinet he grew
up and a lot of the bad habits he
contracted were in that period of being
extremely authoritarian in the way in
which he dealt with his own colleagues
was a throwback to his past but where
bhutto and Buddha was Ayub the field
marshal you finally got rid of him and
this coincided with a large mass
movement that erupted in Pakistan in 68
now there's a lot of talk this year
about the 60s all over the West but the
Pakistani 68 is ignored this was a
student uprising against the military
which triggered off a much wider
movement in the country something that
didn't happen anywhere else consistently
and for three months from November 68 to
march 69 the students and workers and
middle-class layers and the urban
petty-bourgeois layers fought against
the military despite heavy casualties
they suffered and finally won the
dictator was toppled and many of these
activists went into the PPP and many of
these activists went into the PPP bought
because Bhutto was one of the few
politicians who supported the movement
who put himself at the head of it who
became its voice and who denounced the
military with which he had worked in
very sharp language and so and in the
course of this he developed a simple
program wrote iike proud makan food
clothing and shelter for all very simple
but very powerful and this became the
emblem of the PPP this is what we are
going to give you if we win and
country was totally polarized and
Boutros swept the elections in the
western part of Pakistan in 1917
defeating the most entrenched
established landlords all over the
country his party won and the joke used
to be that if a dog stood with the PPP
label the dog would be elected to
Parliament and so there was enormous
expectations then the country split out
and butchers role in that was none too
good but nonetheless after the split he
had the chance to do whatever he wanted
there was no opposition the army was
crushed it had broken up the country it
stood defeated the mood in the country
was we need some radical transformation
so this was really kind of a turning
point right big turning point and it's
very rare for a political leader to be
given the chance to look at the
political landscape of his or her
country and transform it Bhutto was
given that chance and he failed and the
first thing that he should have done is
to do what the Indians did as early as
the 1950s which is pushed through
drastic land reforms ending the
stranglehold of the landed gentry and
the landlord's over that country's rural
life an urban life and politics that
would have been a big leap forward and
secondly what he should have done is to
have built his social infrastructure on
the education and health fronts and
moved the country forward now these were
perfectly achievable targets they it
could have been done if the will had
been there but the will simply wasn't
there instead he got involved in
grandstanding and posturing on the
global stage and nuclear weapons and all
that while the country at how immune of
the people continued to languish mm-hmm
you you say early in your book that you
regret in some ways talking ill of the
dead when you
talk about benazir bhutto who of course
was assassinated only last year what do
you think were her basic failures what
what do you think were the flaws that
allowed her as well to have possibly
taken the country in another direction
you say in conversations with her in the
early 90s that she expressed a lot of
progressive instincts and and concern
about the welfare of the underclasses in
Pakistan yet she too seems to have
failed did she basically make the same
mistake as her father or was it
something different well it was
something different in the following
sense that her father had the
possibilities of doing whatever he
wanted the country was with him the
degree of mass mobilizations was high
the traditional rulers of that country
lay supine on the ground couldn't resist
he could have done anything by the time
she had come to power through an
election Pakistan had been under an
extremely brutal military dictatorship
for ten years plus general CL Hart's
dictatorship which had brutalized the
country and which had forced
Islamization from above that is when
that process started
now when benasi was elected she was
hemmed in by a president with powers who
was a senior bureaucrat in the country
who had collapsed in a collaborated with
the military in getting her father
hanged he was on one side in the
military on the other she told me very
bluntly I can't do anything it's
impossible to act was there you know by
that time the country had been
completely transformed in the other
direction and my advice to her at that
point was even if you can't do much you
have to do some things and it doesn't
require too much money to create for
instance in network of training schools
for teachers
women teachers and setting up schools in
every single village to educate girls I
said you just do that and people who
remember you forever forever and
whenever they talk they'd say she is the
one who gave our daughters education she
you know just lifted her hands in
despair and so I said if you can't do
even that then you have to go on
television and tell the people why this
is one way of educating people telling
them why you can't do it that wasn't
done either and then in her second term
of office her husband the current
president of Pakistan was totally out of
control on the money monetary front I
mean that her second period of office
saw endemic corruption and the massive
accumulation of wealth by the first
couple I mean these figures were
discussed in a Congress US Congress
report in 1999 published in a long
service of their corruption or published
in The New York Times they're all
available so it's not a big secret what
they did and it's that that finally
brought about her fall because a
president she had appointed herself said
we can't go on like this and dismissed
her government so this has been a
tragedy for the country and a loss for
her we're coming to the end of our first
segment but I want to at least follow up
on one point that you make in the book
you you somewhat ironically say that her
at the end of last year she was the one
end of an arranged marriage in the good
old Pakistani tradition between herself
and General Musharraf
who were seen by the United States as
kind of the odd couple who could could
stabilize Pakistan and of course that
didn't work did it why didn't it work
what was the the central principle or
that that went wrong in that arranged
marriage and and I guess we have to do
it fairly quickly we can come back in a
second
well I think the basic reason why didn't
work is that by the
time Sheriff was extremely unpopular
he'd got rid of the judges he was
completely hemmed in and sending in a
laundered Benazir cleaned of all the
charges against her of corruption to
join him created a great deal of
cynicism in the country and as I wrote
at the time arranged marriages can go
terribly wrong sometimes the husband's
family killed the bride in Pocket the
dowry and at other times both parties
suffer and collapse and I'm this is what
happened to these state departments
arranged forced arranged marriage in
Pakistan both parties fell one was
tragically killed and the other is
ayatul fast so they have to start all
over again well I think we'll take a
break now and then in the second half
we'll come back to the future of
Pakistan and where the country is going
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts visit book TV org more with
tariq Ali and robert Dreyfuss in a
moment the head of the national cable
and Telecommunications Association Kyle
McLaren on cable TV's retransmission of
broadcast channels broadcasters are
insist on getting paid a lot more money
which means they're gonna be higher
rates to consumers or if they feel
strong enough in a particular
marketplace particularly at the
Superbowl or some high value contents
coming up they're gonna yank the signal
from a cable operator and viewers are
actually going to lose the signal Kyle
McLaren Monday at 8:00 p.m. Eastern on
the communicators on c-span 2 afterwards
with tareka Lee and Robert Dreyfuss
continues well we've painted a fairly
bleak picture of Pakistan both in terms
of its political leadership and its
historical subservience to American
interests in that part of the world one
of the things though that puzzles me as
well as I think a lot of other people is
is the Pakistani military in bed with
the Taliban and al-qaeda or are they not
it's a it's a difficult question because
when you when you hear the news you see
that the Pakistani army occasionally
sends forays up there as you mentioned
many thousands of Pakistani troops have
been killed fighting the Taliban and al
Qaeda in the border areas on the other
hand you hear that the the ISI the
Intelligence Service of the Army is
supporting covertly the Taliban has
certainly in the past seen them as
allies but even today even after 9/11
see them as a reserve force as a as an
ally you hear talk about a good Taliban
and a bad Taliban from Pakistani
military types who say there are some
who we can work with and others that we
can't try to explain this in a way that
would make Americans understand as you
as you understand it what is the
relationship like between the Pakistani
military and these militants who are
apparently sheltering al-qaeda leaders
and fighting American troops in
Afghanistan let's start with what
happened after 9/11 when the United
States decided they were going to take
Afghanistan take the government in
Afghanistan out and occupy it there was
very little resistance at the time and
the reason there was very little
resistance is that the Pakistani
military told the Taliban people under
its influence not to fight they said if
you fight you'll be crushed it's foolish
if you do that go and take a rest and if
you some of you have to come to Pakistan
come to Pakistan but don't fight the
Americans and this is by and large what
happened I mean a faction led by Mullah
Omar who's then the leader of
Afghanistan I didn't agree with that and
disappeared to the mountains to wait and
they suffered cash
as well during the bombing raids but the
bulk of the Taliban forces didn't fight
back at the time and the unlike Iraq
where resistance began almost
immediately in Afghanistan it took some
time to build up and as if you look at
US intelligence reports in recent years
they blame the rise of the Taliban on
the endemic corruption the heroin trade
and the smuggling that goes on under the
Karzai regime and with which people
close to cars are heavily involved so
that is one thing which we have to
understand why this war has gone badly
wrong in inside that country secondly
both to come down to your question I
think there's probably no doubt that the
Pakistani military is close to one
faction of the Taliban how many people
are in this faction remains to be seen
but the fact there is talk of good
Taliban and bad Taliban inside the
Pakistani military is not restricted to
them alone this is also spoken off in
British and American circles and the
British have coined a new word the Neo
Taliban that this is no longer the old
Taliban that is operating in Afghanistan
but it's now become an umbrella for a
general hostility amongst persons to the
foreign presence and both Britain and
the United States have been talking to
them the u.s. national speaking US
agents go they have conversations they
discuss and what they're discussing is
whether a faction of the Taliban can be
brought into the government of Hamid
Karzai to sustain him and give him a
strength which he's lacking they've
refused they've said we're not opposed
on principle to coalition's but we will
not enter a coalition with a guy who's
totally dependent on Western support and
we cannot enter any government as long
as there are foreign troops on our soil
so they are all being discussed with the
Pakistani military establishment
obviously sees this faction and
preserving it
think that is in their own state
interests so they carry on doing it and
I think often the the mistake is made of
saying that the ISI is somehow different
from the Pakistani military High Command
there may be odd ISI operatives on the
actual border with Afghanistan who
sometimes take unilateral decisions that
is possible it happens wherever
countries are engaged in conflict but by
and large the ISI large though it is is
under the control of the Pakistani High
Command the current leader of the
Pakistan Army General Kayani before that
he was head of the ISI so they have
total control over it and I think it
sometimes becomes convenient from both
sides to blame the ISI it's not that it
is the Pakistani military acting in what
it sees are the interests or its own
interests and the interests of the
country which it has meant to defend
that's what's essentially going on so
there's no surprise to me that they have
links with the Taliban well earlier this
year we had the remarkable event of the
President of Afghanistan Hamid Karzai
and the United States both saying that
they had incontrovertible evidence that
the bombing of the Indian Embassy in
Kabul was carried out by terrorists who
were supported organized by the ISI they
said point-blank that this was a
Pakistani operation of terrorism inside
the the Afghan capital what's your
evaluation of that if the ISI is under
the command of the chief of staff did it
go that high was this rogue operators
within ISI or did they make this up my
information is that the bombing of the
Indian Embassy did involve an ISI
presence but that this was a rogue
element not necessarily even a rogue
element at a guy isolated in the
frontier posts on the Afghan boy
odhh has to deal with local militants
because otherwise he wouldn't survive
and that he authorized this particular
action I'm also told that this is
something which the Pakistanis initially
denied but now privately have accepted
and apologized for to the United States
behind the scenes which is why the issue
is not raised but certainly things like
that can happen I mean you know as well
as I that when a country is occupied you
have rogue elements on both sides you
know who are out of control and who do
things without consulting their
superiors and I think this was one such
incident and it was a appalling thing to
do because it you know both India and
Pakistan are nuclear powers and it
anything that exacerbates tensions
between these two states is just
criminal in my opinion so so this some
and of course Karzai went to the
inauguration of President Zardari when
when I guess he was the only foreigner
present so I guess he's trying to mend
fences or build relationships
I think the invitation to Karzai to
attend the inauguration was a clear
attempt by Safari to say to the US
political establishment I can be yours
as well you've got Karzai I'm just like
him we're both the twins who'll fight
the war against terror for you as long
as you keep on backing me I think that
was a very clear message being sent to
people in the United States who had
helped serve very into power which
certainly wasn't as we now know the
State Department but it was Cheney's
office in Holly's earth who helped to
propel Suvari in too far by giving him
advice by organizing the fall of
Musharraf and this was a very saying
thank you very publicly look I'm
standing with Hamid Karzai who is not a
popular figure either in Afghanistan or
in Pakistan so that was very clearly
intended for the West yeah we talked
earlier about the Bhutto dynasty and and
you you describe the
Pakistan Peoples Party as in your book
as a family heirloom sort of passed on
from generation to generation now the
the young I guess nineteen year old son
of benazir bhutto is the life chairman
of the party or something like that
he seems like a a Machiavellian figure
now Zardari in your book you you
basically blame him for the
assassination of his his son really I
mean that his his brother-in-law
Benazir Bhutto's brother who along with
his other brother formed a militant
resistance movement could you talk a
little bit about that I think it's it's
it's shocking to hear that the President
of Pakistan could have been involved in
the assassination of his brother-in-law
that is what he was charged with as I
point out in the book he was never tried
for that but the case against him was
quite strong I've seen all the
documentation look Bob you have Murtaza
Bhutto who was slain in power in in in
his house family house in Clifton you
have his sister in power is Prime
Minister the police decide to ambush
Murtaza Bhutto as he is going home from
a meeting outside his house senior
police officers are on the scene the
ambush is carried out this boy in some
of the people with him are shot dead he
lies on the floor outside his house
bleeding and it takes ages before an
ambulance even comes to pick him up and
this has not been authorized by someone
high up it's mind-boggling to think that
it could be done the what is said in
reply to these charges is that this was
done yet again by the ISI to embarrass
benazir bhutto and she was in power well
I'd believe that
to be honest I've seen Noah
suggesting that and there is evidence
and you know everyone knows that most
example profanities brother and Safari
lately that's not a big secret
they'd clashed motor Sabu to accuse a
very of destroying the butcher name
destroying the family accused him of
corruption is to denounce him in public
and Murtaza Bhutto was taken out and
senior police officials were involved in
this whole business and the commission
of inquiry that was set up by benazir
bhutto herself pointed the finger in the
direction of safari in the official
establishment so he was never tried for
it so we can't say he's guilty it's
important to make that distinction but
certainly there very few people who
believe that he wasn't ready and it's
important also to say that these are not
just conspiracy theories like who killed
Jack Kennedy in 1963 this is actual
factual material that suggests that the
president of Pakistan was involved in a
political assassination of someone in
his own family and on top of that as you
described in the book literally billions
of dollars are at stake in terms of
corruption there were legal cases all
over the world against him and his wife
to some degree of course his late wife I
think you say that up to a billion and a
half dollars perhaps was looted from
Pakistan by the family so so this is
something that I guess most people who
now see him being lauded as a potential
savior of the country ought to
understand right he's coming to New York
I guess today he's gonna meet with Sarah
Palin
among other luminaries that should be an
interesting meeting what what accounts
for the the plaudits that this man is
getting in the united states well that
he's now decided he wants to be a poodle
of washington he will do their bidding
and from Washington's point of view it's
his
quite convenient to have a creature like
him because they have so much on him
that's you know which which can be used
so I think that is why and you know the
memory of people in this day and age bob
is so short that anyone can be laundered
made to look very clean if the global
media networks in the United States
wants them to but I think that it was
one thing to do that with Bain the same
porto who did have you know there was
still a weather for faction for her in
the country I mean I was very critical
of her that you know many other people
want but for this guy whose last time
there was a big serious opinion poll in
the country his ratings were even lower
than Bush he stood at 14% people don't
like him they don't trust him his regard
is completely corrupt and the fact that
he's now a total poodle of the US will
make him even less popular so from the
point of view of the US interest he's
not a great figure to have running the
country it's it's a big tragedy for
Pakistan this and his particular
elevation to the presidency is I think
probably a very you know one of the more
debased episodes in our country's
history you can't write off what has
been done by these people you know some
people say oh give him a chance he'll
turn a new leaf I doubt it very much
because politics is not the dominant
idea in his head leave alone political
principles this is power for its own
sake the core of your book really is a
discussion of America's role in shaping
and guiding and manipulating sometimes
overtly sometimes from behind the scenes
Pakistani politics you you use a very
funny term in your book you say that in
Pakistan Stooges were often called
spoons and sometimes Pakistani leaders
have been confronted by crowds of people
waving spoons at them to show that they
have can
temp for these these kinds of leaders
you also somewhat Uemura sley described
Pakistan as the condom for the United
States in in its intervention into
Afghanistan but these kind of terms of
ridicule resonate in Pakistan don't they
in a country where you have so little
access to health care to education even
to clean drinking water certainly to
jobs and and you know a live livelihood
of dignity what what effect does this
have on the the country inside when they
see their leaders so overtly
collaborating with the United States
against what most people might think is
Pakistan's own true national interest
well it creates a great deal of anger
akka stan has been blessed with it's
poets they used to be one great poet
Habib jar live now dead who when
president Ayub Khan in the 60s was
coming on yet another state visit to
Pakistan wrote to line poem in which he
said president just one request
just one plea don't go to America
it was rhymes in our language you know a
key I anyway I won't I want to repeat it
and then the same point when Bhutto was
in power repeated that point in public
when she I was in power he was locked up
and used to sing it in prison and this
has been the refrain of our poets and
satirist sand critical journalists from
the beginning of the country until now
Bob and it's still going on you know
this is a country really gripped on the
flight path of us by and now despise
getting closer and closer and the real
needs of the
people are very different these needs
are not being supplied by either the
jihadis who are not popular in Pakistan
at all or the military or the political
class or the United States and the
problems are what you've just described
and what I go into great detail in my
book that the real task is to modernize
the country in the best sense of the
word you know when I was researching
this book I would go I went into places
and talked to people and there was one
family poor family I spoke to rady
poverty-stricken and I said if you had
the choice what would you like the most
and she said for my children all my
children to be educated and for them to
learn English now this surprises people
but the language English as a language
is spoken in Pakistan largely by the
elite and so people see this as yet
another thing which they have no access
to because they see if you know English
you can go abroad you can get her
another education you can read books
which are not available in your own
language
and I often say to friends in Pakistan
that dr. mahat here in Malaysia another
Muslim country has succeeded partially
in modernizing that country and that for
the last 30 years English has been a
compulsory second language for Chinese
and Malays if Marty can do it in
Malaysia why can't any Pakistani
government do it in Pakistan and it's
tied into the fact that this is really
an incredibly corrupt and callous elite
a friend was telling me the other day
that there was a large lavish wedding
from within the elite in the city of
Lahore where there is widespread poverty
and the tents they had organized for the
wedding were mimicking the court at
Versailles in in France in the 18th
century with lots of mirrors etc that
food and wine flowed through the whole
night and outside the wedding
the drivers who brought these people the
chauffeurs were sitting huddled up in
the cold last winter waiting for it and
there is now great great anger on the
basis of the class needs of the poor in
Pakistan you know needless to say most
of this is invisible to American
policymakers at least it's not something
they think about what someone very smart
told me once that in Iraq we didn't
invade the real Iraq we invaded the Iraq
of our dreams and not the real Iraq the
one that we later found to be there in
Pakistan we seem to deal with the
Pakistan of our nightmares the the
country that is the source of terrorism
that strikes America but we don't we
miss the real Pakistan and your that's
what you're describing just now what
what can the United States do to get a
grasp of the real Pakistan and to
understand the underlying problems that
lead to the appeal even of some of these
jihadis to ordinary Pakistanis who are
pushed to the end of their their rope
all they need to do is to open their
eyes pop I mean there's a large American
presence in that region there lots of
very intelligent US journalists who
visit that country and see it they
should report what they seen some of
them do to be fair but by and large
American policymakers look at Pakistan
essentially the gays the u.s. gays as
far as Pakistan is concerned is how do
we use this country to serve our needs
in the region and now particularly in
relation to the occupation of
Afghanistan and that has always been the
gaze of the United States during the
Cold War how to do how do we use this
country as a pawn to marginalize India
which refuses to do our bidding it's
always been like that that the country
is seen in terms of
US interests and not the interests of
the majority of people in that country
and this is partially what has brought
us round to this pass you know people
say yeah yeah we know what we did in the
80s against the Russians and yeah
mistakes were made but you know for you
their mistakes because you're now far
removed from them though they didn't
remain mistakes from the people who
you'd worked with finally hit back in
9/11 former allies so history has a way
of never going away it continues to echo
even if you wanted to forget it and in
Pakistan these echoes are very strong
because people know what was done to
that country and what is being done now
that explains the unpopularity of the
United States I mean the New America
Foundation conducted an opinion felt
some months ago and I think over 60
percent said that they regarded the
United States is the biggest threat to
peace in the region 11 percent said
India which I thought was in you know
did the 11 percent figure was a figure
which filled me with hope the people are
not seeing India as the main enemy in
perpetuity that there is possibility of
changes and shifts in batteries let's
talk a little bit about that hope in the
minutes that we have left here you say
something very important which I myself
have been trying to get across in this
country and in my work that the ultimate
solution for Pakistan is a regional
agreement a regional agreement that
would involve Iran and India possibly
involving Russia and China to some
degrees and other countries that could
create a security framework and a
political framework that could help
stabilize the country and to put it on
the path of economic development as
opposed to the American flight path that
you say in your subtitle talk a little
bit about well I mean the the there too
two related things it's in relation to
Afghanistan when I say you know that we
need an exit strategy
of Grannis town for the West and I said
this exit strategy shouldn't be what was
done in the past is more or less to
Hannover the country to one contractor
let's say the Pakistani military I think
that would not be in the interests of
Afghanistan but I think in terms of
withdrawing from Afghanistan which
should be seriously considered you could
have a regional situation with Pakistan
India Iran in Russia guaranteeing a
government in Afghanistan for ten years
peace because they all have support in
that country and the inflow then
appropriate to rebuild the country after
a 30-year war which has been going on as
far as Pakistan itself is concerned
Bob the phrase I use is that it needs to
read just it's time
Pakistani time has Pakistani clocks
speaking metaphorically are adjusted to
either Washington time or Saudi Arabian
time and they need to be readjusted to
South Asian time Pakistan is a major
country the sixth largest in the world
nearly 200 million people India of
course is the major country in that part
of the world in all and globally but we
need a South Asian Union is what I've
been arguing for now 20 years on the
model of the European Union where the
sovereignty of the individual states is
not challenged but there's an opening of
borders there is trade between these two
countries and the years of war are ended
and there is demilitarization - and I
think this could be done and within this
framework if you take Pakistan India Sri
Lanka Bangladesh Nepal you could begin
to solve the contentious issue the Tamil
question in Sri Lanka the Kashmir
question between India and Pakistan by
the Union guaranteeing the autonomy of
these regions not giving them
independence which many of them don't
even want but guaranteeing their
autonomy
and I think that is the way we have to
look if we want to end this century it
for this region at least on a high note
and and what's the current state of
relations between Pakistan and India of
course they've fought several wars
they've been on the brink of war even
recently in this decade both have
nuclear weapons but they seem to have as
well a process of dialogue and and I
think both countries probably understand
the importance of reaching some sort of
Accord is anything like that on the
horizon or is it too far-fetched at this
point well it is on the horizon but
there is there are no real concrete
moves being made in its direction and at
the same time even as we speak the area
of Kashmir occupied by India has
witnessed the largest mass civil
disobedience movement nonviolent ever in
its history demanding an end to the
Indian presence so it's not the Pakistan
is the only country under pressure on
the northwest frontier India is under
pressure with from within Kashmir of
people who say they don't want to be
ruled by India they don't want the
presence of Indian troops in the region
so in this situation it is essential for
both the leaders of both countries and
other countries to come together and
think of a unified solution which you
know doesn't mean losing any sovereignty
but it means actually creating the basis
for something good filling people with
hope for once rather than despair well
let's hope that the next president of
the United States reads your book